do you think it's
possible to uh within the pan cyclist
framework to measure
consciousness or put another way are
some things more conscious than others
in the pan cyclist view
it's a difficult question i i mean
i do see consciousness as a
dealing with consciousness an
interdisciplinary
task between something more experimental
which is to do with the ongoing
project of trying to work out
what people call the neural correlates
of consciousness what kinds of physical
brain activity correspond to conscious
experience
that's one part of it but i think
essentially there's also
a theoretical question of
more the why question
why
do those kinds of brain activity go
along with
certain kinds of conscious experience i
don't think you can answer that because
consciousness is not publicly observable
i don't think you can answer that why
question with an experiment
but but they have to go hand in hand and
i mean one of the theories i'm attracted
to is the
the integrated information theory um
according to which we find consciousness
at the level at which there is most
integrated information and they try to
give a mathematically precise definition
of that so on that view
you know probably
this cup of tea isn't conscious because
there's probably more integrated
information in the
molecules making up the tea than there
is in the liquid as a whole but in the
brain
what is distinctive about the brain is
that
there's a huge amount of integrated
there's more integrated information in
the system than there is in individual
neurons so that's why they
claim that that's that that's the basis
of consciousness at the macro level now
they
so i don't i mean i like some features
of this theory but they do
talk about
degrees of consciousness they do want to
say there is gradations
i'm not sure conceptually i i can kind
of make sense of that i mean we can
there are things
to do with consciousness that are graded
like
complexity or
levels of information
but i'm not sure whether experience
itself
admits a degree i sort of think
something either has experience or it
doesn't uh it might have very simple
experience it might have a very complex
experience but
experience itself i don't think it
admits a degree in that sense it's not
more experience
less experience i sort of find that
conceptually hard to make sense of but
i'm not i'm kind of open-minded on it
so when we have a lot higher resolution
of
sensory
information
don't you think that's correlated to um
the richness of the experience
so more doesn't more information provide
a richer experience or is that again
thinking quantitatively and not thinking
about the subjective experience like you
can experience a lot with very little
sensory information perhaps
like do you think those are connected
yeah yeah so there are there are
features characteristics here we
we can grade the the
complexity of the experience
um
and on the integrated information theory
uh
they they correlate that in
in terms of mathematically identifiable
structure with
integrated information so roughly it's a
quite unusual notion of information it's
perhaps not the standard way
one thinks about information it's it's
to do with constraining
past and future possibilities of the
system so the idea is in in the retina
of the eye there's a huge amount of
possible
states my the retina of my eye could be
in at the next moment depending on what
light goes into it
uh
whereas the possible next states of the
brain are much more constrained
obviously it responds to the environment
but
it heavily constrains
uh it's it's past and future states
and so that's the idea of information
they have and then
the second idea is how much that that
information is dependent on
integration so in you know in a computer
we have transistors um you take out a
few transistors you might not lose that
much information it's not dependent on
interconnections whereas you take a tiny
bit of the brain out you lose a lot of
information because the way it stores
information is is dependent on
the interconnections of the system
so yeah so that's one proposal for how
to
measure
one
gradeable characteristic which might
correspond to some gradable
characteristic in qualitative
consciousness um and maybe i'm being
very pedantic which is you know
philosophers professional pedants i just
sort of don't think that
is
a quantity
of experience it's a quantity of
the structure of experience maybe but
i just find it hard to make sense the
idea of how much experience do you have
i've got
you know
five units of experience i've got one
you know experience i don't know i find
that
uh
a bit hard to make sense but maybe i'm
being just pedantic
you